>>Female voice: From the Library
of Congress in Washington, D.C.
>>Dan Cohen: Good morning, I am
Dan Cohen, Executive Director
of the Digital Public Library of
America, and on behalf of the board,
the staff, and the DPA community, I
want to welcome you to DPAfest 2016!
[applause] So this marks DPLA's
third birthday and we're thrilled
to have you here for two days
of workshops, activities,
conversations, and so much more.
The people in this audience really
make DPLAfest and make DPLA itself.
We have so many people
in the audience to thank,
for what really is a
gigantic, collaborative effort
to maximize access to
our shared culture.
And we've got a particularly great
lineup this year, with attendees
from across the country and
indeed around the world.
We have people coming in from
Japan-several people from Japan -
and Europe and other
places to join us,
and from so many different
institutions and fields
and disciplines and walks of life.
And really out of this diversity
and great spirit we can
do great things together.
I'm particularly delighted to
be hosted in these wonderful,
treasured spaces in our nation's
capital: the National Archives,
the Smithsonian, and right here
in the Library of Congress.
This space is really terrific.
It's great to be here.
The DPLAfest program
is bigger than ever
with headline panels taking
place right here, today,
in the Coolidge Auditorium, as well
as smaller focused presentations
and workshops happening in
other spaces in the Library
of Congress throughout the day.
Tomorrow will pick up where we
left off at the National Archives
and the Smithsonian's Riply Center
for even more presentations,
workshops, and engaging discussions.
We've got so much to do that I'll
keep my remarks brief this year
since we have an incredible lineup
of speakers here in the plenary.
First of all, I just want to thank
the Library of Congress so much
for graciously hosting us today.
And thanks also to
the National Archives
and the Smithsonian Institution
for hosting us tomorrow.
In a few moments, I'll
invite the heads
of these distinguished organizations
onstage to say a few words
to kick off this year's DPLAfest.
And we're also joined here
by our essential funders,
public and private, who
really have enabled all
of the work that we've done to date.
I also want to highlight the DPLA
board which is up here in the front.
Maybe, DPLA board if
you could stand.
We have both original
members who have been here
from the start [applause] and
we have some new members as well
who are joining us to provide
new ideas and new energy.
I'm really thrilled that
they could join us as well.
We also have our staff.
They are here, mostly over here.
You will recognize them
by their yellow lanyards
and frequently having a DPLA shirt.
Maybe if, staff, if you
could just stand up,
just so people can say hello.
[applause] There they
are, our intrepid staff.
If you need any help or
assistance they are here to help.
Also since I have brutally
overworked them the last few days,
if you want to give them
a high-five or a hug,
they would appreciate that.
Thanks so much to the staff.
So without further ado, let me give
you some updates and some milestones
of where the Digital Public
Library of America is.
So first of all, this is
our biggest fest to date,
and we have over 450 registrants.
And so many more hoping to attend.
We had a very long waitlist;
we're very sorry for those
who are tuning in from afar.
We'll do our best to
inform you via social media.
I'll give my yearly reminder.
We paid a lot for the DPLAfest
hashtag, so please use it liberally.
We're also recording sessions,
including this one and those
that are taking place
in the auditorium
and those will be available
online after the fest.
We also have the broadest array of
programming to date at a DPLAfest.
We have 65 sessions.
I want to in particular thank
Kenny Whitebloom, our DPLAfest czar
who has been able to
put this all together
with the staff featuring 170
speakers over the two days.
We're really thrilled that since
the inaugural DPLAfest in Boston
in 2013, the fest really has become
an exciting event for so many people
from so many places, so
many cultural institutions,
places in education and law
and technology and libraries
and archives and museums and
authors and publishers-all
of them have made DPLAfest a home
and a place to talk to each other
and a central part of their year.
Let me know talk about the growth
of DPLA and our national network
which really is at the
heart of what we do.
Our hub's network provides
access to digitized content
and it's growing at a furious pace.
Here's the map from our launch
year in 2013 and you can see
that we just had fairly
scant coverage.
And here's where we are right now.
We have a footprint now with service
hubs in almost half the states
and many more in process to join
and we're really looking forward
to completing this map
in the coming years.
It's something that's really
quickly coming into reach.
Many thanks to our funders and
the efforts of our community
to support full coverage, so that
really any collection of any size
in the United States has
a way to join the DPLA
and to distribute their
content nationally,
and, indeed, internationally.
We really are approaching the point
where we have a true
national library.
Actually, can I have members of
our hubs stand up in the audience
and let's thank them
all for their work
in putting together this
national collection.
[applause] We're also
delighted to announce
that we now have 1900 contributing
institutions to the DPLA.
An amazing number that's
up from just 500 contributing
institutions at launch.
And this includes institutions
like the Smithsonian,
really large national
institutions with millions of items,
and it includes in the lower right
the Core Sound Water Fowl Museum
in North Carolina.
[person in audience shouts] Shout
out to the Core Water Fowl
Museum fans in the audience.
Yes, I put that slide in for you.
It really is a combination
of heterogeneous institutions
of all sizes working together.
The diversity of our collection
has also become astonishingly rich
because of these 1900 institutions.
We have millions of books-2.5
million books in the collection now.
We have a million photographs.
We have maps, we have artworks, we
have so many other kinds of items
that we are adding and our growing
audience is increasingly viewing
and watching and listening to what
we've been able to put together.
It's really terrific,
however I am sorry to report
that we recently discovered
we are missing one item type:
our staff did a census
and unfortunately we do not have
any selfies in the collection,
so I'm actually going to
rectify that right now.
[laughter] Okay this is the
participatory part here.
Are you all ready?
Okay, here we go, we're
going to take a selfie.
Actually, it's an "usie"
Okay, here we go.
[laughter] [inaudible]
Well done, I'm texting this
to our social manager right now
as we speak and this will go out--
synergy here-- in our new Instagram
account which you can follow online
and so you can follow it there.
I will try to do this
at the same time.
Okay now that we have satisfied
the exhibitionists in the audience,
I would like to say that if
you are someone who likes
to keep more private, you're not
a selfie person, we're delighted
to let you know that DPLA
is moving to https for those
who want an encrypted
connection to our site.
[applause] We're not 100% there yet.
Most of the site works, we have a
very complicated tech environment
with the DPLA, but, if you want,
you can in fact start browsing DPLA,
dp.la in https rather
than plain old http.
And the DPLA tech team is working
to iron out any remaining problems
in the next couple of months.
The API will also be secure.
So, shout out, can I have a round
of applause for the tech team?
Tech team, stand up,
also for their work.
Thank you.
[applause] Good dancing there,
director of technology
Mark Matienzo.
Last year we kicked off a new
initiative around education,
exploring the ways DPLA's
rich content can be used
in the classroom.
With enormously helpful funding
from the Witing foundation,
and our educational advisory
committee, and our staffers,
we've been able to
produce primary source sets
that can easily be
added to any curriculum.
Earlier this week we
announced that we are now
up to 100 primary source
sets, all free and open,
gathered from those 1900
institutions, the best material
from across the country all ready
to be dropped into any syllabus,
any curriculum, start using them.
If I can get a round of applause?
I know our educational advisory
committee is scattered throughout
the audience.
And also Frankie Abbot and Samantha
Gibson, our staffers who worked
so hard on the primary source sets.
If I could get them to stand up
and we can thank them as well.
[applause] I'm also delighted,
last year at DPLAfest we announced a
partnership with PBS Learning Media
which reaches so many teachers
and students every year,
and I'm delighted that those
same primary source sets are now
available through PBS'
digital media learning site,
pointing to our primary source sets.
They're all there live
so that people can find
this wonderful content
where they're looking for it.
Another major initiative that comes
to fruition today is
our collaborative work
around rights statements--
that is clearer ways to
express what you can do
with these millions
of items in the DPLA.
And I should announce that we
now have over 13 million items,
as of today, in the DPLA.
[applause] Yes, that's great news.
These are large-scale
digital collections,
and one of the things we've found is
that it is hard for those teachers
and students, and the
general public,
to understand what they can
do with these materials.
Sometimes the rights
statements are not very clear,
and we knew that the same thing
was true among our partners
at Europeana, who are here today.
They also are making tens of
millions available and there are,
indeed, collections across the globe
that make library archiving
museum collections available,
but the right statements are
unclear and we have worked so hard
over the past two years, thanks
to Knight Foundation funding,
to streamline these
rights statements
and to make them international
and interoperable.
Super clarity.
And we are delighted that
today, I should also note,
we worked with Creative Commons
who provided advice and DPLA
and Europeana have launched
RightsStatements.org.
You can go there right
now, [applause] yes,
worth a round of applause.
Again funded by the Knight
Foundation and in collaboration
with Creative Commons, Kenisland,
and key stakeholders of Europeana
and DPLA networks, we received so
much help from members of our hubs.
We've created standardized
rights statements that will,
for the first time, make it easier
for cultural heritage institutions
and aggregators to
communicate the copyright status
of cultural heritage objects online.
And really what that means,
at the end of the day,
is for users of our sites,
it will become so much easier
to understand how they can use
the objects they discover via
our platforms.
These right statements will cover
three general categories of rights
around items held in our
cultural heritage institutions.
I just want to highlight
here, Ryan Janelle,
who did the creative commons
logo, has done, in fact,
our rights statements logos.
And you will see these across
websites in the coming years--
they'll be very clearly
identifiable.
These statements in fact talk
about three general categories:
those that are in copyright will
be very clearly labeled as such,
those that are not will
be labeled as such,
and those where we are a little
unsure about their status will
at least be clearly labeled as
being within that confusing category
and leave it to the end user
to decide what to make of that.
There are a variety of
statements that come out of this,
in those three categories, and you
can read all about what they mean
on rightsstatements.org right now.
It is live.
We have a press release going out.
And we're just delighted about
this work we've been able to do
in concert with Eureopeana
and friends
at Creative Commons and other hubs.
So actually if I could get-- we have
members of Europeana who are here
who worked with us on that.
Harry and Paul and
others and Antoine
and also Emily Gore led
this effort from DPLA.
[applause] There's Harry.
Eureopeana has been such great
friends of DPLA from the start
and we're really thrilled
that we could work
with them on RightsStatements.org.
So you can get ready to
see these marks associated
with cultural heritage
items internationally.
You'll be able to search
collections so much more easily,
for those items, for
instance, that can be reused.
And they'll take their place, I
think, in a very complementary
and supplementary way with
the Creative Common marks,
which of course can only be applied
of course to items you create
or recent items that Creative
Commons licenses can be applied to.
So I'm really thrilled about the
launch of RightsStatements.org.
They're also, for the nerds in
the audience, machine-readable.
They have standard URI's.
So this will all be
connected together on the web.
Finally I want to give a brief
update on a really exciting project
that recently launched and which
fits into DPLA's mission as I put
at the start as maximizing
access to our shared culture.
The Open E-books Initiative
generally supported by the Institute
of Museum and Library Services
and the Alfred P. Sloan Foundation
and in collaboration, really
a strong collaboration
with our friends at the
New York Public Library,
as well as First Book
and Baker and Taylor.
And with 250 million
dollars in e-book donations
from award-winning front-list books
from major publishers has
experienced really just tremendous
uptake in just its inception.
As we announced earlier,
we went over a million access
codes distributed, there's an app
that kids can download after
their caregivers apply,
and kids in low-income
areas can access thousands
of books, completely for free.
And they're, in fact,
reading hundreds of thousands
of books have already been read.
We're excited that these kids are
getting access to these things.
We see on social media
these wonderful photos
of kids using these things
in Indiana and Anacostia here
in the D.C. area and other places.
This has been part of the White
House's ConnectEd Iniative
and the White House has received
hand-written letters like the one
in the upper right that
really express thanks.
And really at the end of the day,
it's not about distributing access
codes or the technical platform,
although these are
wonderful, incredible things,
at the end of the day really
this what we all want, right?
We want kids to read wherever and
whenever, whether it's in paperback
in the backpack or phone
in the back pocket.
If I could have those in the room
who have worked really overtime
for the past year and a half
to launch the Open Ebooks
Initiative, if you could stand up.
I particularly want to
highlight our friends
in the New York Public
Library, Mika and James,
and at DPLA, Rachel and Michelle.
[applause] Simply amazing work
to get these books in the hands
of millions of kids
across the United States
to access these wonderful ebooks.
So lots of great news
in the DPLA community.
We've got one more bit of good news.
And here, I'd like to
hand the mic to-this going
to sound a little biblical-but
we have three
"David"s coming up on onstage now.
[laughter] And I'd like to start
with the acting Librarian
of Congress, David Mao.
We're so appreciative, again,
to the Library of Congress
for hosting DPLAfest and for
working so closely with us
over these next two days
and we're looking forward
to further work with them.
And here's David to talk
more about our relationship
and the wonderful work the
Library does online and off.
[applause]
>>David Mao: Good morning, everyone.
And thank you very much, Dan,
for that wonderful update
on what DPLA has been doing.
I'm very happy to welcome all of
you to the Library of Congress.
We're very honored to be
cohosting this DPLAfest 2016 along
with our colleagues at the National
Archives and Records Administration
and the Smithsonian Institution.
DPLA has come a long way
since it launched in 2013,
as you heard Dan just mention.
The statistics are amazing.
From a few million to now-- over
13 million I think you said,
in just a few short years.
Clearly DPLA is well on
its way toward its goal
of bringing together
libraries, archives, and museums,
and all of the wonderful content
in all of these historical places
so that they're freely
available for students,
researchers, and the general public.
Now as supporters of America's
archives, libraries, and museums,
many of you already probably know
much about the Library of Congress:
that we were established by
an Act of Congress in 1800
as the first federal
cultural institution here
in the United States; that
it was our third President,
Thomas Jefferson's, personal
collection, or at least part of it,
that helped seed the collection
here to develop into the library
as we know it today; but many of you
may not know that today the Library
of Congress has over 162
million items in its collection
and multiple, multiple
petabytes of digital content.
And so we are a very large
institution and we welcome you here.
Actually, let me see a show of
hands, to the extent that I can see,
how many of you for you this is
the first time that you've been
to the Library of Congress?
Okay, that's pretty good.
Actually I'm pleased with that
result because there weren't
that many and, I guess with a
room full of library, museum,
and archive lovers,
that's to be expected
and I welcome you back
to the Library.
But for those of you that
have not been to the Library
of Congress before, I hope
you'll take this opportunity
to really explore us, get to know
us better, there's time later
in the schedule for you to take
a tour of this historic building,
which was first opened in 1897.
The Library was originally
in the Capitol,
it was a very small library,
and then this building
was created in 1897.
But we have three buildings
here on Capitol Hill,
a facility up in Ft Meade,
Maryland, 25 miles away.
We have a state-of-the-art
facility for audiovisual materials
down in Culpeper, Virginia.
And we have six international
offices, so we are delighted
that you are here and hope that you
will experience the Library while
you're here and get to know
us and want to come back.
And for those of you that
have been here before,
certainly please feel free to
explore and see some of the changes
that have taken place and some
of the exhibits that we have
up since perhaps the last time
that you were here visiting.
So you're visiting the Library
at a very historic time.
In the 200, almost 216
years of existence,
we've only had 13 librarians
of congress.
I think all of you probably know
that the last librarian of congress,
James Billington, now the
librarian of congress emeritus,
retired last fall and the President
has nominated Dr. Carla Hayden,
currently the CEO [applause]
Dr. Hayden, the current CEO
of the Pratt Library up in
Baltimore to be the next--
14th Librarian of Congress.
And so we at the Library of
Congress are just delighted
that the process is moving forward
and we look forward to the future
of the Library of Congress.
I also want to thank very much David
Ferriero for asking the Library
to join in with both the Smithsonian
and the National Archives
to cohost this event.
The Library of Congress is not
currently an official partner
with DPLA, though I should
probably say that over 100,000
of our digitized book files are
currently available through DPLA
because of our participation
with the HathiTrust,
but I'm happy to say right now
that we are working very closely
with DPLA looking to bring
closer our collaboration
and we've started initial
discussions with DPLA
and we look forward to a happy
announcement soon enough.
But today is just the
first step in terms
of our continuing collaboration.
We're very happy to host DPLAfest
here at the Library and I just want
to welcome you again and
hope you enjoy the rest
of your time here at the Library.
Thank you.
[applause]
>>Dan Cohen: Thanks so much David.
And we're looking forward
to working with you as well.
Next up is David Ferriero
of the National Archives.
This is the problem.
Sorry, I'm going to
change your names now.
David Ferriero, who's
really just been a friend
since the planning phase
of DPLA and, in fact,
they hosted the very first
DPLA plenary meeting in 2011.
I was there.
We now have almost two million
items from the National Archives.
Thanks, David.
[applause]
>>David Ferriero: I
believe it's more
than two million, isn't
it, right Pam?
[audience member: Yes] Okay.
So good morning and
welcome to Washington.
When was the last time you were
introduced by three Davids?
I'm really pleased to be cohosting
this event with our colleagues
from the Library of
Congress and the Smithsonian.
Thanks to all of you in the room.
I'm very proud of what you have
all accomplished and the fact
that you have joined
us on this journey.
I was in that room on the
Red Cliff campus in October
of 2010 when DPLA was born.
And a shout out to Bob Darnton,
our spiritual leader [applause]
who convened us, encouraged
us to be bold,
to think big, and to be inclusive.
In my head the "D" in DPLA
will always be "Darnton."
Thanks, Bob.
I'm so proud of the role the
National Archives has played
in getting us to where we are today.
Today and tomorrow many of
my staff will be presenting
on their innovative projects ,
including sessions on making gifts,
developing digital
collections for K through 12,
as well as "gamifying"
transcription.
We'll host a hackathon.
We'll talk about mobile apps,
APIs, and our work with Wikipedia.
These topics that were foreign
to our agency just a few short
years ago are now critical
to our mission today.
I'm excited to see our agency moving
forward and leading in these areas.
But what I'm most excited about is
the historic partnership you will
see over the next couple of
days among the Smithsonian,
the Library of Congress,
and the National Archives.
Our three institutions have
been working together not only
to host this event, but we've
been exploring further ways
to work together on a
variety of projects.
It just makes sense to work together
since we share similar
missions and common challenges.
We can help each other.
For example, our three institutions
are developing a project
to digitize World War I content
and increase the creative
reuse of these records.
Staff from the National
Archives, the Library of Congress
and the Smithsonian will introduce
a mobile app at this conference
as well as discuss opportunities
and challenges we see
in working together.
The point that is clear
to all of us is
that collaboration is
the path to the future.
We are all on that
path today with all
of our institutions working
together to make the vision
of the Digital Public
Library of America a reality.
Open access to the collections
of major cultural, historical,
and research institutions improves
democracy through education
and furthers the principles
of open government.
We welcome you here today for
the third annual celebration
and I look forward to welcoming
you to my house tonight.
[applause]
>>Dan Cohen: Could we
have the slides back on?
Thank you!
Our final David, last,
but certainly not least.
Secretary of the Smithsonian, David
Skorton, who will say a few words
and of course Smithsonian was
a founding hub of the DPLA
and we have eight million
items now-I'm worried
about getting the numbers
wrong-maybe more?
From the Smithsonian, David
Skorton, thanks so much.
>>David Skorton: Thank you.
What you may not realize,
even Dan may not know,
is that the three Davids were
actually triplets separated at birth
and our organizations
use us interchangeably.
If they're not getting along with
one of us they just swap us out, so.
[laughter] I do want to also
want to welcome you on behalf
of the Smithsonian and my other
partners and I'm very very honered
to be doing this with the other two
Davids and the other supporters.
A little tiny bit about
the Smithsonian.
It was founded in 1846, so
we're celebrating our 170th year
and we have a collection-your
collection-of 138 million things.
127 million of them are biological
specimens of various kinds
and the remainder run the
gamut, very very broadly.
We also have 19 museums
and galleries,
the National Zoo, and 20 libraries!
All right!
And I do want to acknowledge the
work of my predecessor, Wayne Cluff,
who was secretary and also acting
Smithsonian provost Richard Cure,
many of you who may know, who
were there, as David said,
at the start of the DPLA in 2010.
And both embraced the Smithsonian
mission or the motto of our founder,
James Smithson, to found an
institution for the increase
and diffusion of knowledge.
And the diffusion part is
unbelievably important.
And 1.25 million objects are
represented from the Smithsonian
in DPLA and many others, and
we've had over 2 million viewers
of Smithsonian object on the
DPL site, so far as we can tell.
And I want to acknowledge even
though I don't she was able
to be here today, our
wonderful Smithsonian Librarian,
Nancy Gwynn, many of you may know.
I was at the Library
of Congress recently,
thanks to David's gracious
invitation, for a tour
and I was just fascinated.
And among many other amazing things
about the Library of Congress,
they have a collection
of musical instruments,
and I'm a failed flutist
and so they allowed me
to briefly play a beautiful
Boehm, 19th century flute.
They heard a couple of notes and
they grabbed it away from me.
But afterwards I decided to
go online and search the DPLA
and I found many many interesting
source photos and documents
and had a little tiny bit
of first-hand experience.
It's enormously exciting.
It's enormously inspiring.
And it's enormously important.
And I hope that the remainder of
the time you have is useful time.
I hope that you enjoy the numerous
variety of things to do here.
That you explore all three of our
institutions, and most importantly
that you have a chance to talk
with each other and push each other
to make this incredibly important
project even more robust.
Thank you and welcome.
[applause]
>>Dan Cohen: Wow, thank you
so much to our three hosts.
We're just again delighted
to be here and delighted
to see their collections in person
and to have conversations
in their spaces.
Thanks so much again to our hosts.
We also want to thank some
sponsoring organizations
for their support of DPLAfest:
texthelp, Digital Transitions,
and the Digital Library Federation.
DLF actually sponsored
travel for some attendees
through cross-pollinator grants.
And Texthelp and Digital
Transitions, I believe,
will have demo space tomorrow
at the National Archives.
Finally I'd like to just give a
sincere thanks to our funders.
They have provided such important
and continued support or our mission
and everything you've heard so
far this morning and will hear
about in the next couple of days.
Starting with the Alfred
P. Sloan Foundation, IMLS,
the Knight Foundation, the National
Endowment for the Humanities,
the Whiting Foundation,
the Mellon Foundation,
anonymous donor, and others.
They've all really worked
together as a community
to really enable what
we've done as a community.
I'd like to begin with Doron Webber
of the Alfred P. Sloan Foundation,
who will say a few words
about Sloan and their mission.
[applause]
>>Doron Weber: Thanks, Dan, it's
really a pleasure to be here
and this is almost what a certain
politician would call "yuge."
You've really got a lot of
people; it's really wonderful
to see how far this has come.
The Sloan Foundation, we make
grants in science, technology,
and economic performance and this
is part of a program that we call
"Universal Access to Knowledge"
which aims to use advances
in digital information technology
to make the fruits of scientific
and cultural knowledge available
for the widest public benefit,
upholding the highest
standards and values.
And before I begin with the
funding of DPLA, in the pre-DPLA,
it's interesting, our first grant
actually went to the Library
of Congress, which
is hosting us here.
It was in 2004, and as a funder
you know usually I'm pursued pretty
avidly, but in this instance I had
to almost force the grant upon them,
not because they didn't
want the money,
but because everyone was talking
about digitization at the time,
but there was fair amount of
resistance to how to do it
and we managed to get
the grant through.
The Internet Archive,
Brewster Kale, gave us machines
and the Library started digitizing.
And at the time, you know
they had 34 million books,
I'm not sure how many you have now,
and I asked so how many-everyone
was talking digitization-how many
are digitized?
And the answer was 5,000.
So we gave them the first,
I think about a hundred thousand
mass digitization effort.
I think they them created
the FedLink system
which continues to this day.
And so that was the beginning
of the pre-DPLA days.
The first grant, which
David alluded to, in 2010,
Sloan arguably I think we made
about seven to eight million dollars
in grants but maybe the most
important was 36,388 dollar grant
to the Radcliffe Institute
with Robert Darnton as the P.I.
and that was to bring
everyone together in one room.
There was a lot of talk about
starting a national digital library,
but we had a lot of people who
wouldn't speak to each other,
there were a lot of
conflicting views.
We got everyone together
in one room and we talked
and then I said the equivalent of
locking the doors here and said,
"we can't leave until we have one
sentence we can all agree on,"
so we wrote a sentence
together as a group.
I was at the whiteboard
and people would correct me
and make contributions.
The sentence, I think I remember
it is, "an open distributed network
of comprehensive online
resources that would draw
on the nation's living heritage from
libraries, universities, archives,
and museums to educate,
inform, and empower everyone
in this current and
future generations."
That was the-remembered that!
[applause] That was the
founding charter of the DPLA
and that was what we
in the foundation would
call the deliverables,
actually had something
concrete for that grant.
And then of course we started
with the Berkman Center.
John Palfried did an incredible job.
We gave them a grant, the creative
secretariat of work communities,
six workstreams, wiki,
a website, a listserv,
we started having meetings, OSI
and NEH, I think, came on board,
Amsterdam, met with Europeana,
I think in June we gave a grant
to Berkley Law Center to work
on the copyright obstacles.
In October of 2011, David, we kicked
off the plenary, and actually one
of the funders not listed, so
Sloan put in 2.5 million dollars,
but the Arcadia Fund matched us,
our good friends Peter Baldwin
and Elizabeth Rousing and we then
had a two year process with a lot
of meetings, a lot of
workshops, a lot of conversations,
a digitization prototype-building
pilot and a community-building
because DPLA at the end
really is about community.
And we launched in 2013,
within a month it was named one
of the top 50 websites
by Time Magazine.
Sloan made a grant, I
think in December of 2012
to find an Executive Director,
we had a national search,
we were fortunate enough
to find Dan Cohen.
And since then, the
Knight Foundation,
IMLS helped build the hubs,
I think as Dan showed you I think
half the nation that we're hoping
to complete by 2017, so there's
been remarkable progress and it's
to be applauded and usually I
play the role of cheerleader,
but I would just encourage
us to do even more.
I think it would be great.
First we need more funders.
Gates, you know not
to mention names,
very generously gave a
million dollars but Gates is
about twenty times
bigger than Sloan,
so if you take our seven million
and multiply it by twenty,
that's one hundred and
forty million dollars.
139 more to go, Gates.
And we would like similar
contributions
from good friend Darren Walker
at the Ford Foundation, others,
I think, we would like to see them
step up and increase the staffing
and let DPLA really become, I'd
like it to be like Wikipedia.
We're still the largest funder
of Wikipedia and I'd like it
to be a model of what
you can do on the web,
and we'd like to see DPLA
play that kind of role.
We're also very proud of the
progress on the Open E-books.
Dan is to be applauded.
I think Tony Mark Seer of the New
York Public Library played a really
critical role and we'd like to
continue you that and build that up
and continue to let DPLA play
that kind of leadership role.
So anyway, thank you very much.
You should all feel proud
of your role in this.
We're living in a kind
of very strange time
and I think the importance
of knowledge and access
in a safe environment where values
of transparency and universality
and rationality and truth are
even more important than ever
so I commend all of
you for your roles.
Thank you very much.
[applause]
>>Dan Cohen: Thanks so much, Doron.
The National Endowment for the
Humanities has also been there
from the start as a key funder.
I just also want to give a shout out
to their staff as well who have been
so incredibly helpful along the way.
Chairman Bill Adams is here to talk
about NEH and the way that our work
with the National Endowment
for the Humanities has helped
to really promote the common good.
So, Bill. [applause]
>>William Adams: Thank you,
Dan, and good morning, everyone.
What a great turnout.
What a wonderful audience.
So many wonderful friends
of NEH here.
It's really great to be here and
to just share a couple of thoughts.
It's hard following
the three Davids,
not least because of the object
envy that I'm experiencing.
All those millions of objects, of
course NEH doesn't have any objects.
We support a lot of
objects with our work.
As some of you know, this is the
50th anniversary of the signing
of the act that brought
us into existence.
September 29, 1965 the pen of
Lyndon Johnson creating the NEA
and the NEH.
We haven't collected
objects over that time,
but we've given away 5.3 billion
dollars in about 63,000 grants
to humanities institutions and
scholars all across the country.
So, those are our numbers,
not objects,
but hugely important
numbers in the grand sweep
of the humanities community
of this country.
[applause] Thank you.
We share a lot in common with DPLA
and I'm sure that's what brought us
in to this very significant project.
The values, first of all sharing
the value of demonstrating the value
to the significance of this
cultural heritage of this country,
a hugely important
value to us at any age
and I know for the DPLA as well.
And attached closely to that
providing open public access
to those extraordinary riches of the
country which are coming together
in so many interesting
ways in this project
and stimulating collaboration and
partnerships among organizations
that either own or have
access to the things
within that extraordinary
cultural heritage.
And last but not least I think
we all understand the growing
importance of the digital universe
with respect to the humanities
and how much of interest is going
on in the humanities community
because these extraordinary,
wonderful digital technology.
As Dan said, we were among the
first funders of this project
and we're proud to be
so, having given a grant
of nearly one million dollars
to help create those first four,
I believe it was, original hubs.
A subsequent grant of $250,000
supporting the extension
of those hubs.
The present is enormously
impressive and to see the progress
that has been made since
that first grant is terrific.
13 million objects as you've heard.
Extraordinary promise for
educational institutions,
particularly the K through 12
universe which I think needs a lot
of help now, especially in
preserving and extending
to students the humanities
legacy of this country.
NEH is working to help
advance the important work
of this important organization
and initiative.
In 2015 alone we awarded about 3.5
million dollars to 29 projects,
which will lend all of their
digital content to the DPLA portals
so there is more coming by way
of the other grants we're making.
Also, we're experiencing
local organizations
that we're helping are now
able to share very very local
and specific content some of
it private until very recently
through the DPLA portal
that's becoming part
of the national cultural
legacy as well.
The other interesting
recent development.
Some of you know about
our collaboration
with the Mellon Foundation
in the Open Book project
where we're digitizing important
humanities texts now out of print
and we're helping presses-university
presses,
primarily-bring those items back
into print, not into print actually,
into digital format, all of which
will be available through the DPLA.
This is going to be about 500
titles now out of print will be free
and open to the public through
the DPLA and other resources.
In sum, we're very proud of this
investment and what it's done.
We're enormously grateful for all
the hard work that's brought it
to this place and we're very excited
about the porspects for the future,
especially as it affects access
and the implications of that access
for the educational
world and the work
of humanities education
around the country.
Congratulations and
thank you very much.
[applause]
>>Dan Cohen: Thanks, again, to NEH.
The Institute of Museum and Library
Services has also played just a
core, instrumental
role and I just want
to thank them again
and staffers at IMLS.
Maura Marx is I will
mention not only the Director
of Library Services at IMLS but
she was in fact the director
of the DPLA secretariat in its
planning phase and really deserves
so much credit for everything
we've talked about today.
Maura, could you come up and
talk about IMLS and their role?
[applause]
>>Maura Marx: Thank you, Dan.
It is amazing to be
here with all of you.
I'm bringing my laptop not because
my memory is not as good as Doran's
but so that you could see the
battered DPLA sticker there
on the front of this laptop.
So as you know, IMLS is the
federal funder of libraries
across the country and we have
been proud to support DPLA
under our national digital platform
priority from the very beginning.
For us the national digital
platform is a way of thinking
about digital capacity
in the country.
It's a way of thinking about
funding technology and services
that will enable libraries
to leverage
and benefit the work
of other libraries.
That we work towards
interoperability rather than silos
and that we work towards
the broadest possible access
for all people.
So we have been thrilled to support
DPLA's work in two major areas.
The first one is the
hydra-in-a-box project.
Which you know, which is a
community repository project
that will enable lots of smaller
institutions to get into DPLA.
So we're thrilled about that.
And the second is the Open E-books
project which you just heard about.
The evolution of that.
You know, it started as a project,
it turned into a presidential
initiative to get e-books
into the hands of economically
disadvantaged kids and it was built
around software developed
by New York Public
Library and funded by IMLS.
We think this e-books
work is so important,
not only because of the kids it
serves, but because it involves DPLA
in delivering in-copyright content.
DPLA was founded, as we've heard in
October 2010, in part in response
to unresolved copyright questions.
It was founded on the idea that
the policy and legal environment
in this country had not kept pace
with developments in technology
and in content and that if we had
a community developed blueprint
for a national strategy, we
could create a living, breathing,
all-encompassing digital library
that did not stop at 1923.
So it is awe-inspiring to
stand here today and celebrate
with you the tremendous progress
that DPLA has made in
the last five years.
1900 institutions-that is
really, that is truly awesome.
To have in sight a DPLA
that encompasses all 50 states
is just truly breathtaking.
It's moving to be here in
the Library of Congress
as we await confirmation
of a new Librarian
who will surely face new challenges
and opportunities in the discussion
around copyright and copyright law.
And we're proud to work with
Sloan, with Knight, with NEH,
hopefully with many new funders,
as you continue working towards
that goal of a truly universal
library that will educate,
inform and empower all people.
Thank you so much, DPLA.
Can't wait for the next two days.
[applause]
>>Dan Cohen: That is a nice
looking battered sticker there.
It's like an old punk
sticker or something.
Finally, George Martinez
of the Knight Foundation.
I mentioned earlier the launch
of the RightsStatements.org,
our new international,
interoperable,
clear rights statement
around library,
archive, and museum content.
Knight has not only funded
that, but funded hubs expansion
and has also funded some
exploratory work that we're doing
around newspapers, which
we're hoping to tell you more
about in the coming
months and years.
George, if you could come up?
[applause]
>>George Martinez: Good
morning, everybody.
I'm the chief technology
officer at Knight Foundation.
I've also had the privilege
of spearheading our universal
access in library work.
Now Knight Foundation is a national
organization with deep local roots
in 26 communities that had
Knight newspapers at the time
of the passing of our last
funder, James Landon Knight.
Along with his older brother, John,
who preferred to be called Jack,
the brothers took a small
bankrupt newspaper from Akron,
Ohio and turned it into what was
the largest American newspaper
and media in the seventies.
They did this by emphasizing
quality journalism,
smart business practices,
and good old horse trading.
And by horse trading I mean,
I think there was actually
a thoroughbred involved
in the acquisition of one of
the newspapers in Kentucky.
[laughter] But that's a
story for a different time.
Now Jim ran the money-side
of things out of Miami
and Jack was a consummate newsman,
who, out of office in Akron,
was the only publisher
for all of the papers
until his passing in 1981.
They were what we would call today
fast followers of innovation,
always willing to use
new technologies
that would help them run this
disperse empire that went
from coast to coast in the US.
Telephone, teletype fax, satellites,
you name it, they tried it.
Sometimes they didn't work,
sometimes their ideas were just
a little bit ahead of their time,
but they weren't afraid to try.
Now, profits and losses are
the same, wherever you are
in the United States, but Knight
brothers didn't want all their
newspapers to look exactly the same.
They didn't want the
Detroit Free Press to look
like the Akron Journal just
because they were all involved
in the automotive industry
or that the Philadelphia Inquirer
should mirror the Miami Herald
because they had a lot of tourism.
Jack emphasized, no
better yet he demanded
that each paper reflect
unique character and flavor
of their communities
that they were in.
From their writings and speeches
we know that they believe
that democracy thrives
only when the people
in those communities are
informed and engaged.
And this also happens to
be our mission statement,
creating informed and
engaged communities.
It's because of this
emphasis on creating informed
and engaged communities that
Knight started funding in the areas
of universal access and libraries.
And, you know, when you look
at it, what institutions
in our communities today
really says informed
and engaged better than
the public library?
It's the most democratic
and egalitarian institution
we have anywhere.
The best description I ever heard
at one of these conferences was
that libraries are
democracies best kept promise.
I think that's true today
and that's been true forever.
So, I gave you this little brief
history of Knight Foundation
so that you can really
understand why the DPLA
and the grant proposals they
submitted to us resonate
so strongly at Knight Foundation.
The original grant for the core
infrastructure and hubs reminded us
of how the Knights successfully
ran their newspaper empire.
With the hubs leveraging
what was unique to each state
or regional partner and the core
infrastructure brining it all
together, while creating a useful
platform to access the information
or create new versions of the
content on that information.
Also DPLA has not been
afraid to experiment
and tackle difficult areas.
Things like digital
rights and copyright,
issues that Dan alluded to.
They've also not hesitated to reach
out and collaborate with colleagues
in Europe and Australia,
which you will hear more
about during this next two days.
And, near and dear to
our journalistic roots,
is DPLA's exploration of how to
bring born-digital newspapers
and content into the fold and make
sure that these aren't unavailable
or lost to future generations.
And finally and selfishly to
me as the relationship manager
for this grant, the success of the
original hubs has created demand
to expand into more of this country.
So as I look out today and see
all of you in this audience,
I'm really heartened that
all the new faces here
that I see joining the faces I've
seen before seems to be growing.
And, you know, for me as a
funder, I've got the easy part.
Giving away the money might sound
difficult, but it's not that hard.
[laughter] Doron might
argue with me.
It's you, and the DPLA
staff, and all the folks
that have been involved in directing
the work of the DPLA over the years
that really have the difficult
part and are making the impact.
So I encourage you to
continue supporting
and contributing this
important effort.
We're all grateful for everything
you're doing, and I hope to see more
of you at the next DPLAfest.
Thank you.
[applause]
>>Dan Cohen: Thank you George,
and the Knight Foundation
and to all of our funders.
We have many in the room as well
and we should thank them
all for their support.
Are you ready to fest?
Here we go.
Okay. Before we finish
up, just a few bits
of housekeeping which
will be important.
We have a number of
fabulous panels today.
You can see the chairs here.
They will soon be filled
with wonderful people.
And so here in the Coolidge
Auditorium all day we will have some
headline sessions on
the future of libraries,
authorship in the digital age,
technology trends in libraries,
just to name a few, and we also
of course have smaller sessions
that you can see at
least electronically
or on the beautifully printed
program in smaller venues.
We are really packed to the gills
here, we have over 450 people,
and so we're going to do our
best to accommodate everyone,
and so rooms will be a little
bit first come, first serve.
So if you for some reason are
stacked up or outside the door
in one of the smaller rooms, you
can of course always head back here.
There'll be seats here for you to
use and you won't be disappointed
with any of the conversations
in this room.
Now today we're at the
Library of Congress,
but we're actually in two buildings.
This is the Jefferson building,
as David Mao noticed, mentioned.
You'll also notice in your program
that there are also programs
in the Madison Building
which is across the street.
Now there is a tunnel between the
two buildings, which is really fun.
If you've never been in the tunnel
between the buildings of the Library
of Congress, I encourage
you to take it.
There will be signage and in
fact we have three Library
of Congress staffers
who will now wave.
Maybe if we could life the
lights just for a second.
So there's one in the back there.
So there will be Library of
Congress...yeah, there we go.
Oh, and down here, yes!
So look for your friendly Library
of Congress staffers to connect you
to the tunnel if you need to get
over to the Madison Building.
Again, all event staffers, I'm
not wearing my badge right now,
but all DPLA staffers and Library
of Congress staffers will be
wearing the yellow lanyards,
so look for those lanyards
if you need any help.
One note, also about lanyards.
We provided red lanyards for those
who do not wish to be photographed,
so as you can see we have a
professional photographer here.
Other people may be taking
photographs, so just keep in mind
if some folks do not
like to be photographed,
they're wearing the red lanyards.
We have box lunches distributed
from the Great Hall here
in the Jefferson Building
and Madison Hall if you're
over in the Madison Building.
We're going to do our best to divide
up those lunches in
those two places.
Do your best to be
wherever you want to be
in the afternoon-the
first afternoon session.
If you could pick up a lunch
there that would help us insure
that we have enough people
in both places as well.
David mentioned it's
a great opportunity
to tour these wonderful buildings,
to get to know really all
your federal institutions
over the next two days.
From 12 to 2 today, so over
the lunchtime two hours,
there'll be five different stations
around the Library of Congress,
here in the building: docent
stories, background information,
architectural details, it's in a
really truly incredible building.
If you've never had a
tour, I encourage you
to build your own here
in the building.
The Library of Congress shop is
offering a ten percent discount
at their shop.
I spoke to a Library of
Congress staffer last night.
Evidently their socks
are best sellers.
So I have not checked out the
Library of Congress socks,
but I have heard that they are
truly incredible and bring revenue
into the Library of
Congress that they can use
to digitize more content
that will end up in the DPLA
as part of our partnership.
[laughter] So I encourage
you to sock it up
and get whatever else you
want, again with your lanyard
of any color you'll be able
to get a discount there.
Reception.
We're going to have
an amazing reception
in David Ferriero's home tonight
in the Library of Congress-Library
of Archives-National
Archives building.
[laughter] At 6:30.
Stay with me.
There'll be hor'doeuvres,
there'll be drinks,
there'll be special events,
there's going to be trivia contest,
there'll be tours of the
Amending America exhibition
and our recovering the
classics popup gallery.
These are wonderful public domain
books that have been reinvisioned,
covers reinvisioned by artists.
Terrific. Okay you need to
be sure, this is important,
to enter via the special
events entrance tonight
on Constitution Avenue
between 9th and 7th street.
The special events entrance I
believe is closer to 7th street.
Here's the key part: please
don't forget your badge.
Bring your badge.
Wear your badge to
the special event.
Bring your name badge.
No number of Davids will help you
if you do not bring your name badge.
Tomorrow we will once again
be in the National Archives
for the second day and the
Smithsonian Ripley Center.
Two wonderful places to be for
the second day of the fest.
There will not be a kickoff session,
I'm sorry this is the most
you'll hear from me and,
like there was today, you'll
show up to where you want to go,
again, check your schedule.
Breakfast and lunch again, breakfast
and lunch will be available
at both locations, both the
Smithsonian Ripley Center
and the National Archives.
If you want to walk between the two,
it is a beautiful walk
across the mall.
We included a map in your packet,
so you might want to review that.
Finally we'll have a wrap-up session
at the McGowan theatre at 3:15pm
in the National Archives building.
And it's just going to be
a brief wrap-up session,
we'll talk about some of the
great things that have happened
over the past few days,
some wonderful outcomes.
There's hackathons going
on, there's all kinds
of wonderful conversations.
Again we hope to see
you all there tomorrow
at 3:15 tomorrow afternoon
to wrap up.
Finally, once again, there it is,
the wonderful DPLAfest hashtag.
Use it in your favorite
social media app.
We encourage everyone to live tweet.
For those who are not here,
we're excited to capture the
conversations, the presentations,
and just the fun that we're
all going to have together
over the next couple of days.
So that's it.
Have a wonderful time
at DPLAfest 2016.
We're so delighted you're here.
And enjoy.
[applause] This has
been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov